there we go
[Music]
all right Katie last year I'm in an Uber
on the way home from work as one does as
one does the Uber driver has got his
crypto account open while he's driving
while he's driving and he's showing me
all the money that he's made on crypto
over the last few months and I'm not
talking Bitcoin or ether here I'm
talking coins you can say that I just
did okay and he's like okay when it
starts he's so easy when it starts going
up you buy and then when it gets really
high you sell I've heard that before
well that's what he was doing yeah and
all I could think of to myself was this
is the top you know when your Uber
driver is showing you how much money
he's made in crypto and how you got to
get in on it and I'm thinking this is
not going to end well for this guy and
sure enough here we are a few months
later two trillion dollars in crypto
value has been wiped out and I'm not
hearing Uber drivers talk about their
crypto anymore well if that story is
true and it sounds super fake let's just
establish that I promise it happens okay
well if it's true it actually was pretty
close to the Top If You Think about
where we were around November of last
year close to a record high on bitcoin
and to your point we've just seen this
tremendous drawdown of wealth since then
and I actually think that creates one of
the more interesting moments in crypto
after the summer we just lived through
where it felt like everything blow up
now's the moment where the industry sort
of has to decide where to go from here
whether this is a 2018 moment after that
boom and bust which went on to build an
even bigger bubble or whether we're
entering a phase of the crypto ecosystem
where it's more mature so luckily for us
we have eight episodes to try to do that
I have all these papers in front of me
and we're going to try to figure out
what moment we're actually in right now
and funnily enough we actually prepared
something no kidding yeah we did
[Music]
it only took a few months but more than
two trillion dollars in crypto wealth
was wiped out we're talking wreckage
that was far and wide here yeah we got
the billionaires on one side but we got
everyday people who lost their life
savings
we saw currencies collapse there were
Mass layoffs at companies and some of
these companies were once valued at
billions of dollars declared bankruptcy
so what happened well there was the
collapse of this so-called algorithmic
stable coin and what that did is it set
off this chain reaction that brought one
of the best known crypto hedge funds to
its knees we got to go back to May to
understand what really happened here the
collapse of Tara USD this is an
algorithmic stable coin and it once
topped the charts now it's not exactly
clear what set off the slump in demand
for UST but then we saw this death
spiral and it knocked UST off its one
dollar Peg
think about this as like the crypto
equivalent of a bank run at the same
time crypto had been falling in price
since the end of last year
but then as Tara was melting down the
Panic started to spread and it dropped
the price of Bitcoin by nearly 30
percent in just a week
the problem is that lenders were using
Bitcoin for collateral and that just led
to Carnage across the industry take
three arrows Capital it was this
previously Invincible hedge fund it once
managed as much as 10 billion dollars
and it declared bankruptcy this was just
a mess but it's a mess that we've got to
make sense of and we've got to
understand a 60 billion dollar collapse
of an ecosystem that led to a massive
decline in the price of Bitcoin and then
the outright collapse of companies it
was contagion but it was contagion that
raises really important questions what's
the collateral damage to an industry
after an event like this and perhaps
most importantly
have people just lost faith in crypto
[Music]
all right we have a lot of questions
we've got Stacy Marie Ishmael she leads
crypto coverage for Bloomberg arguably
the busiest woman at Bloomberg it's been
a moment it's been a moment and
I guess when I think back to the summer
of 2021 that run up to last November
where we reached the record high in
Bitcoin one of the big bullish mantras
was institutional adoption sort of
traditional Wall Street embracing crypto
and when you say that we're kind of
learning the lessons of 2008 what is the
reputational damage here is that no
longer really a narrative that holds
it's been interesting to see
institutions
Plunge in not just like a toe in the
water at the same time that retail
investors are a little bit more skittish
and a little bit more inclined to sit on
the sidelines so you know just in the
past six months you've had BlackRock
announce a partnership with coinbase
you've had Goldman Sachs make certain
types of derivatives available to
clients even more recently you know you
have kind of Citadel Fidelity and others
saying they're going to back something
like a crypto-esque Exchange program so
I do think that one of the interesting
features of this institutional adoption
is they're like we're already regulated
we know how to do this we have all of
the available licenses we understand how
to manage risk and they're seeing
opportunities is there concern that
right now
the everyday person the normal retail
person is just completely scared away
and is going to potentially miss an
opportunity because they got worried
about what happened you know post Matt
Damon and they're just saying I'm not
going to touch this stuff anymore
there's a few different ways that we're
thinking about that on the one hand you
know if you were a
to the Moon yield farming I'm looking at
19 different protocols you know you're
like yeah done with decentralization on
the other hand if you're somebody who
watched perhaps your friends perhaps
your family perhaps yourself lose your
life savings in something like Voyager
or Celsius then maybe you're going to
look at a citadel or a Fidelity or a
black girl can be like they seem like
they know what they're doing
their presence might be reassuring to
you so you've got sort of competing
Dynamics in the Market at the same time
sort of the adults in the room that's
what they would like you to say yeah and
here I am saying it so there you go I am
curious though I mean it feels like a
lot of the chaos the contagion was
centered around these crypto lenders and
I'd love if you could bring out your
crystal ball and gaze into it and tell
us are we ever going to go back to the
days of like 18
returns or lending returns or is that
over
if I can answer this question accurately
I would be in a very different job
however I will say that as a person who
covered the financial crisis for a while
they were like we'll never go back to
XYZ and then like three years later
somebody was like I've got this really
exotic product I want to sell you and
the memories and the timelines that we
tend to operate on in crypto are even
shorter right where sort of in the dying
Embers of
um Luna and the the associated
stablecoin you had other folks being
like this is why our algorithmic stable
coin is going to be fine so I think
there is an kind of an inertia built
into the system of anything that we
invent can only be positive unless
there's widespread evidence of the
contrary and then we'll just do V2
Okay so for the past few years people in
the space have been telling me when I
don't understand something it's like
it's the early days of the internet this
is like the 1990s when you know
Andreessen had just invented Netscape
and you know we're trying to figure out
what you can do with this thing
if if that's accurate did what we see
in the early part of 2022 the explosion
was that the.com bust
one of the things about the.com bust is
there were clear winners that emerged
from it but you couldn't really tell who
those winners would be at the time and
so I do think that some of the immediate
speculative excess got rung out of the
market very hard and very fast and very
painfully for a lot of people involved
but you know it took years for Amazon to
become Amazon and it took a while for
people to be like ah pets.com
waspets.com and we are still in you know
sort of the immediate aftermath of that
where it's like you don't know who the
Amazon is going to be and who the
pets.com is right I mean Amazon's
actually only been a profitable company
reliably for like not that many years
exactly so there was this really Grim
time a few months ago when things were
crashing message boards were filled with
people you know anecdotes of people who
lost everything our colleagues here at
Bloomberg published a story about people
who lost everything with voyager I mean
there were people who were talking about
self-harm in in these forums
and I'm just wondering what we've heard
from the industry over that period of
time I wouldn't say there's been a ton
of self-flagellation or even kind of
explicit whoops are bad it's much more
around one a lot of people are getting
sued and when you're being sued actively
by thousands of people it is perhaps
against the advice of council to be like
well we made mistakes because that would
be appearing to admit guilt of some kind
it makes sense but I also think there's
a there's a nihilistic streak in crypto
that suggests that well you should have
known what you were getting into like
you know how come you you invested more
money than you could afford that's on
you if you were margined and leveraged
up to your eyeballs that's on you we
didn't tell you to put your life savings
in crypto and I do think that's a
problem for the industry because it's
the kind of rhetoric that Regulators do
not seem best pleased by because it
reminds them of things like
um the earlier days of sports betting
and gambling before those were
recognized as you know having
potentially addictive properties and the
messaging around that really had to
change so I do think there has been
an insufficient amount of Contrition
relative to the amount of boosting that
there was by a lot of these folks what's
happened instead is people are just like
deleting tweets taking down YouTube
videos being like the haha just kidding
JK and I don't think that that is
necessarily endearing themselves to the
people who did lose everything but again
there's always a new there's always a
new buyer right there's always somebody
who's coming in for the first time and I
worry about that new buyer
foreign
extremely cool woman also the chief
strategy officer of coin shares
Melton when we think about the past few
months really even the past few years
have we extended out people uh cranks
have been warning that this would end in
tears basically this big run-up we saw
across the ecosystem but when you think
about what actually happened the way
that the cards fell how obvious was it
did it happen in the way that maybe had
been expected
yes and no I think there were always as
early as 2018 2019 when the derivative
side of Bitcoin markets and crypto
markets more broadly really started to
take off and institutional lending
started to emerge one of the common
narratives in the media was oh Leverage
is going to be the undoing of crypto and
as we've talked about before in crypto
markets leverage functions very
differently than in traditional markets
in traditional markets you can use
existing Securities and what we actually
ended up seeing there were all these
rumors all the speculation in
traditional media around decentralized
Finance or on-chain financial products
being the undoing of crypto and very
ironically or in sort of an interesting
twist it ended up being the application
of traditional lending models I.E
uncoateralized or under collateralized
lending that caused this massive wave of
washouts were you guys exposed to that
at all you know coin shares or uh in
Venture Investments that you've done
yeah so so we had minimal exposure we
had a small amount of exposure to Tara
which was the Luna stable coin which
were publicly listed so it was in our Q2
financials had very little impact on our
business so knock on wood and congrats
to our risk management team for for
doing a good job there and then the big
part of the ecosystem I'm still
concerned about is crypto miners wait
why so in the mining business model
mining is an interesting sort of area
and I come from oil and gas industry so
we're accustomed in the oil and gas like
real mining like real digging real
mining real digging they're not talking
computers
drills correct yeah if you've never seen
a Christmas tree which is the thing that
goes on top of a Wellhead highly
recommend but um you know what tell me
my Tick Tock and Instagram are like all
like people doing oil drilling I don't
know like how did the algorithm it's
like I like mechanical things so it's
like Emily explains yeah like it's like
airplanes and like oil rigs and stuff so
I feel like I've learned a little bit
real mining so the challenge with real
mining is is um it's a very Capital
intensive because you have to buy A6
these specialized semiconductors used
for mining or gpus in the case of
ethereum or fpga is in the case of zero
knowledge proofs like you buy physical
stuff
um and that physical stuff's expensive
and when you raise capital in a
particular Venture Capital people don't
necessarily want to give you money to
buy a bunch of depreciating Hardware so
you finance it there's a lot of
specialized lenders in the industry who
specialize in lending using the actual
chips themselves is the collateral so if
I want to borrow say 500 million dollars
to build a new data center to mine a
cryptocurrency I may
pledge those machines as collateral to
secure the loan so there's this
interesting Capital recursivity that
starts to happen and what also happens
is you have operating expenses your
operating expense is the cost of energy
and no matter what type of compute you
do all Computing requires energy right
energy in a semiconductor and so the
challenges Energy prices are rising a
lot of the contracts that facilities
have in place these power purchasing
agreement or ppas were not well
negotiated because a lot of people in
the crypto mining space aren't
necessarily from the traditional
infrastructure space and so Energy
prices rising semiconductor prices
dropping so the value of your collateral
that's secured your loan is going down
they don't have collateral to top up the
loan so I end up having to sell Bitcoin
at greatly reduced prices and their
price to mine a Bitcoin then starts to
exceed The Profit they make so creates
this really interesting sustainable
Finance challenge where the fundamental
economics of the business stop working
but in a sense that's actually similar
to what happens with real oil and gas
absolutely so if the price of oil Falls
below that's a natural gas right Shale
gas if it gets too low then it's not
worth it to actually extract it exactly
so you know Shale gas probably five or
six dollars per million cubic feet to
get out of the ground and gas prices for
a long time were two to three dollars so
those economics don't work so what's
that number for Bitcoin for Bitcoin
right now the cost to mine a Bitcoin it
really varies right so the operational
efficiencies really depend on how you
set up your infrastructure what your
power costs are what your interest rates
are on your machines what your cost of
equity is on other Capital you raise
people always tell me to zoom out though
like when it comes to the inflation
hedge our unit can we put it to bed
though can we agree that it's not an
inflation no because I also I'm gonna go
with the the zoom out I think the
challenge is Bitcoin has never existed
in an inflationary environment until
roughly nine months ago so I do think we
need to give it a bit more time I've
never existed in an inflationary
environment yeah although if we look
back at the data if we zoom out enough
oh my gosh yeah you're not going to get
to the year that she was born there was
still no inflation right no inflation
but there has been inflation in in
certain areas and deflation in other
areas yeah right thanks to Technology
Innovation right like amazing thing so I
think those three factors taken together
just create a lot of uncertainty and
then I do think the one thing that we
don't talk about enough and again at
coin shares we have an amazing research
team
people always try to find factors right
and and understand okay what factors are
going to influence price Direction on
this asset class
so much of it is narrative driven so
much of it is narrative driven so much
of it is psychology driven and I do
think there is an element of religious
belief that underpins a lot of this as
well well I want to get to that
religious belief because we saw a lot of
excitement in the last year when we saw
record highs not just for for Bitcoin
and for ether but for everything
coins number go up baby yeah yeah and
I'm wondering if if the industry
if you think the industry needs to
apologize for anything
uh okay so this is a really interesting
question and this again is where I think
um the consumer protection debate comes
in so on the one hand the reason that we
have a lot of the Securities laws the
capital markets laws we do in the United
States is
a regulator or an external body doesn't
necessarily have the authority to say
this is good this is bad what they have
the authority to say is here are the
rules here's the information we need
this is what needs to be provided right
being publicly listed is not a barometer
of quality it's barometer if you having
filled out the appropriate work
paperwork and having provided financials
and the level of transparency that will
allow investors to make an informed
decision right so this is about people
making informed decisions I think the
challenge with crypto is so many people
in 2021 especially we saw this in 2018
and before that in 2014 so many people
view crypto and so many people online
marketed crypto as a way to get rich
quick
so people were marketing a lot of these
things as an easy button and as you and
I and everyone know sorry there is no
easy button
um and I think the challenge is that a
lot of people had incentives to Market
certain things is safe to encourage
people to invest in certain things and
also people don't want to do their
diligence the point I'm making and what
I'm trying to illustrate is this is not
a phenomenon that's unique to crypto it
exists in all parts of the market can I
just say to maybe defend the crypto
industry a little bit more think about
the traditional currency industry Forex
scammers on Instagram I just can't I
want before basically crypto exploded
the way it did in the pandemic so my
favorite accounts on Instagram were
these like Forex scammers like flexing
like their guccis
I think you make a good point yeah but
you're not seeing those advertised in
the Super Bowl no no but so it did it
did reach a different level but some are
you saying well I mean a Forex scammer
is different from like coinbase buying a
Super Bowl ad right
which by the way you know that Super
Bowl ad was that The Cure it was just
the QR code bouncing around yeah it's
kind of a baller move to spend yeah
millions of dollars on a little fancy QR
code so it sounds like the the I mean in
your opinion the industry does not have
anything to apologize for it's more like
I think apologize is a challenging
a word I think there are certain
individuals who maybe behaved in a way
that is
not great but I'm not a judge I'm not a
jury I'm not an executioner I do my best
to not engage in that behavior I never
tell people invest in this buy this do
this
um so I can't speak for that I'm not the
moral compass of the industry I got
another challenge like it's
decentralized it's leaderless by its
very nature I think it's very difficult
for any one individual or entity to sort
of claim moral superiority including the
US government by the way for this very
precise reason you just started yeah
yeah it's a slippery slope I understand
what you're trying to arrive at
um I do think that certain Executives of
certain companies that lost
the millions tens of millions billions
of dollars of consumers
funds
um they definitely have explaining to do
and I do think they'll be held to
account because a company exists under a
legal structure in a jurisdiction with
protocols but you have a really cool
story where you recognize something
early on when it came to bitcoin what
did you see when did you see it
and
I mean yeah I mean and how much Bitcoin
did you buy then so on the last question
are you a nice try IRS
okay you're not going to tell us how
much Bitcoin you bought no I'm never
going to tell you that okay but what was
the price of Bitcoin when you first got
in uh when I got in it was around 150
and then
I went through a period where when I
first started working I was making less
than I had before grad school and I was
in a lot of debt because I'd had a
scholarship for my company to go to grad
school and then I didn't come back so I
lived in a rat and Fest apartment in New
York and I used every paycheck to buy
more Bitcoin wow and then the price of
Bitcoin went from 300 to 120 dollars and
I did not feel great about my life
choices but it was really funny because
people look at it now and they're like
oh did you have some intuition I'm like
no I just thought it was really
interesting the people I was interacting
with like I'd never interacted with
people like that before professionally
and I was like this is wild it's fun
it's really crazy and insane see I would
have said yes I did have intuition and I
can see the future and you're not a part
of it and it was fun you know what I
miss there is a certain joy in believing
something that no one else believes in
and willing to grind to like prove that
you were right are those days over
though no
or you could make those kind of outsized
returns on
a coin or crypto
um I don't think it's a coin anymore I
think where the world is Shifting to I I
do think um what is going to generate
outsized returns is capturing and
creating by the way Trends so I do think
identifying emerging cultural movements
or communities early and investing in
the financialization of those cultural
movements is going to be a huge thematic
Trend and so that is really interesting
it's one that a lot of people aren't
talking about aren't looking at so I do
think there's still opportunities
they're just not going to be as easy
because there's a lot more Capital
there's a lot more people so you have to
be willing to go where other people
won't go and lucky for me I like really
weird people I like really weird things
and I'm willing to bet enormous amounts
of money on really crazy ideas but I
think that's where the returns will
continue to be Malcolm Demers it's great
to see you great to see
you influencing
it was okay yeah
do it again I'm down all right cool
let's do it see ya
[Music]
[Music]